we told you earlier that the fda has
authorized two big steps to make coveted
booster shots available to millions more
americans the agency authorized boosters
for those 18 and older who received the
johnson and johnson vaccine and for
seniors and others at high risk who got
the moderna vaccine visor boosters as
you know have already been authorized
for some patients those shots could be
made available in just a few days if the
cdc advisory committee approves the plan
at a meeting today and that is expected
president biden's chief medical advisor
you know and well dr anthony fauci joins
us from nih headquarters in maryland to
sort this all out for us dr fauci always
good to have you here because you've got
the answers this is big news about the
boosters a lot of people think good news
in the effort to keep us safe but here's
a question how for me how safe should
you feel
if you've been vaccinated but you don't
have a booster yet especially those who
got the j and j vaccine what are your
thoughts on that
well first of all the the vaccines from
the original regimen that we got still
holding
really quite well
when it comes to
protection against severe disease and
hospitalization
but we know from our own experience here
in the united states
as well as more extended experience in
israel that after a period of time that
protection wanes it protects
against severe disease pretty well but
the protection against infection and
then ultimately against severe disease
tends to diminish over time so even
though people right now who've been
uh vaccinated within the last several
months can feel comfortable if you
really want to have the optimal
protection gail then the people who are
qualified and eligible to get the
booster should do it the good news about
what you've just mentioned in your
announcement is that now everything is a
level playing field those who got j and
j
those who got modern and those who've
gotten pfizer there's availability now
to get boosters for all of those people
who are in those three separate groups
and we're talking about mixing and
matching if you got the j and j would
you get another j and j vaccine i know a
lot of people who have it are sort of
freaked out about what they're hearing
about the j and j booster or the j and j
vaccine
well you know it really depends on your
own individual preference and consulting
with your physician about where you fall
in for example your age or your gender
or whether or not you're a man or a
woman there are different i mean the
risks for adverse event scale are really
very very rare and very very low
but in a certain situation for example
if i were a woman
i would probably
not have any problem at all with an mrna
because the rare
rare adverse event with the mrna is
almost exclusively seen in young men so
you really have to balance what the risk
benefit is but i want to emphasize that
the risk of adverse events is really
very very low
good dr fauci um mixing and matching can
be a term also used to describe the
messaging surrounding covert
when it comes to what people are saying
about johnson johnson for example you
have said that this should have maybe
been a two dose shot in the beginning
and now people that have the johnson and
johnson vaccination are saying they
should get a second shot is there a
better way for experts to get that
messaging out there so people at home
aren't distrustful or confused or even
hesitant to go into getting vaccine or
booster shots
well messaging is always a very
important part of a public health
program you're absolutely correct i
think now with the announcement that was
just made from the fda
and the recommendations that will almost
certainly come imminently very soon
certainly from the cdc that things will
really be very clear of what people can
and should do you're right when you have
three separate vaccines that have
different characteristics there can be
confusion but i think right now things
are going to be pretty clear when people
hear what is available to them and as we
mentioned the mix and match
really gives a good deal of flexibility
to people in whatever it is that they
want to choose and the cdc i am sure
will come out with some pretty clear
recommendations depending upon what
category you fit into
all right dr anthony fauci we thank you
for your time this morning i i do think
this is very encouraging
that the booster to make us all safer um
for whatever it takes to get us through
this thank you so much